good morning Hank I'd like to talk about
The Catcher in the Rye today or else the
amazing nerdfighter gathering on 8808
but you challenged me to discuss the
political situation in Georgia while
putting on a peanut butter face and so
it shall be I got the generic stuff
because you know get to go in on my face
[Music]
everyone knows Hank the only way to make
the internet pay attention to news is by
a peanut butter face
okay so George is this small country
just southwest of Russia that used to be
part of the Soviet Union but before it
was part of the Soviet Union it was an
actual like honest-to-god democracy from
1918 to 1921 and it was busy developing
this very close relationship with
Western Europe Oh history will you ever
stop repeating yourself then in 1921 the
USSR invaded Russia mostly because
Joseph Stalin who was born in Georgia
was like you know in like 20 years I'm
gonna want to kill about 500,000
Georgians and that's gonna be way easier
if we invade now so they did and Georgia
became part of the USSR
okay so flash-forward in 1991 the Soviet
Union's breaking up in Georgia declares
its independence right this is followed
by your standard buddy coup mini civil
war etc during that time it turns out
that two provinces South Ossetia and
depth Asia don't want to be part of
Georgia they want to be independent
countries presumably because the world
does not contain enough Luxembourg's now
Hank on the face of it I'm in favor of
MKS you're having its independence if
only because it's would be national flag
wants to give you a high-five but the
history of the actual place of Abkhazia
is significantly less awesome for
instance in the early 90s they
ethnically cleansed hundreds of
thousands of Georgians South Ossetia
which by the way has a lame flag is as
you might guess just south of North
Ossetia which is part of Russia so
basically the deal they end up making is
that South Ossetia and Abkhazia will
have a kind of semi sovereignty to them
sort of like the Kurds had in northern
Iraq between the Iraq Wars and this goes
reasonably well for a while until a few
years ago when Mikhail Saakashvili
becomes the president of Georgia by the
way he has a fun name to say Saakashvili
it's delicious right so Saakashvili sees
that the future of Georgia is really
with Western Europe so he's in favor of
joining NATO and eventually he wants to
be part of the EU and as we know from a
couple of years ago in the Ukraine when
former Russian territories want to
become close to Western Europe
you can go a little bit bonkers like
poisoning presidential candidates
bonkers so that's the background for
August 1st 2008 when someone it's not
clear who through an artillery shell
that someone else that kind of stuffs
been happening for a long time in south
ossetia but this time it was different
because on the day that the opening
ceremonies of the Olympics started the
Russian army decided to come to the aid
of the South Ossetia pnes and blow the
crap out of Georgia I mean not only did
the Russian army enter South Ossetia
they also enter depth Asia and then they
ended up invading large parts of Georgia
and bombing the capital and then after a
week of that Russian president named
only because everyone knows that Putin
runs everything to me Truman fed yet was
like okay that's enough you've been
punished Georgia I mean Hank he
literally used the Russian word for
punished like Georgia is his naughty
nephew so Medvedev has agreed to give up
fighting provided that Georgia give up
both South Ossetia and Abkhazia which in
the end they're totally gonna have to do
because everyone knows that neither
Western Europe nor America will come to
their military aid which is pretty much
Medvedev's point Putin and Medvedev
don't particularly care about South
Ossetia Orab Kaija but they do care very
much that Georgia is becoming closer and
closer to the west and this war has been
nothing more than Russia reminding
Georgia that the West won't come to your
aid and we can pone you whenever we want
Hank it's not the place of a man who's
covered in peanut butter to speak ill of
others but that's lame that's my basic
problem with most Wars there is stupid
as they are evil anyway let's hope the
Georgia continues its path to democracy
and economic growth hmm generic peanut
butter are good so Hank that's my
armchair political analysis with peanut
butter on my face I'll see you soon and
now Hank I'm going to show you the
happiest dog in the world
all right Willie you've got exactly five
seconds go one two three four five
that's it